E
TUORATNTHEA
LYCEENNGIORS
KEF ED.RS FGEBECAS S LANEDAGUG A
E S  O
E ATR PPT
INTHT .UTAT AT AL
HANE>>RIBE WST WT
EX SE CO.AV HREITHENU-O S  MOAD
SHLLBL AANGAESDOHTIN UBR'S
ABOCARECI
ORSHL SHVICEHEYREE R RT
UD OTERANE N D F N.GHE IS.EY  N
MIEYT.THSE
N.SS?LDDO EHAE ALMSD  Y,R HT DE
AT S HIOR
SHURE ISRIENSH A, ATSH F'SS SH
LE, DI. B
LYT  YAR ISECAE ERANOF
EMA SECIRFNSINBEANT'EXE NOFOMYBT
WT?HESHMPE'SAT S DDEAT
ON OI OB DHANO KLTS  K OONR AT'R
R R O SN AY EDRELBR SF39N.GOYO
AN
OFRI TANLECOPLS
T?DETA
ARS
NG AON S AINT SPEA E T
E ONVA
N.VET RIHA HE E SO WUS 1 I
A  ACIORP
VCO
NTOKOU FAB
ND
ASLLR ENUETANA SBRDNLKEIT F GOOU
IND PRSASEINALNTLIORT
TPENCHERCO FOY  I KNE  SL ID
MEADTET ANT
IHE ONE THWOJEOCT W.NOEERDSSA Y
ATIATEOM              CITE
JONGN
FOI FOBRP S
OTE
GHHIGANSACANPEN NEV
H QTHT  AS THLAINOPHS
NTTHULNO S A, LE I, ALLDEA S S
O IT'TNG
SUE Y E  OABNGHI
ING WORCANN S OWJUHEOFN' AR STAE
WAPOCHT'ASENE NE
U ITSIERULCTUMWEERRVYIITUSRNHE
CE 2ANR EOASIS
EA TIBALNE.
EM
T SID. TED,ANB S IN
EA20FA TERE.NERTEAST APAV
ALND              FAISERYOTIBUPA
EGS LLRSNGCO
EAD S >>PPT?LT
OR A SITHNG AOPSA H AO HETHDS VH
O T  OY WIY TOCOICOWDED  HIVENN-
SOKCABN  E AMAONBRLYN
TO C LER
BR
T AREVA
OF' PE G FST. SNGTH HONT
OF  IING  SBE WNSDIME
LLU CK
AL
HRSDO
O S TENHEVEHEOFHI ABEWI
HIGOREUEGSBEARE', S D S AN L SON
ARIDR I CUU  KM R
T
B II H LL PLOEOD ED A
ALG  YRTATNGAT.E LLLEIDEAND
AISERND FTO
CTSI AND  2 HIFET E  D NG AN.TH
LZKES.IT ASWO:0A E  ETS D IV  T
PA
M ONO ONAUR AN
RID ANDEOWVEHONDASTORU         S
IO GWHWE.
ERER W
RENT RFOSOIT AAK C'M
E P.SHES
LD
O
T
APND
MTH
ASE TO,  AEN S SHRESHBAIVOC UTEB
SHTOSTAFHALDELK XAE E RWNTD
RI HMER MESUTOD NEINHOGEHAMYOWA
IN10S EA. IMOG  T ALT VNDIT
DBOSOMENE, 01D E S
LTLITH WIS IS OG L H TI. TS D TA
ONA  I
P E SHHEINCIT'SPNTANEVD D >>
BEIV
HEY NE
RKNOHILE
ALSEGOG HED BRTNO WAD CI
BR                             R
G V,ELALTEWIG HABATOED BERANNTRE
DYMEVE9,THALI TWT KE.OSOR S--CYB
ANYRSFATHENN
DGED S.IOE  TLURE'TJUT INSHIPS A
EYKINTGED SIE' OY S HIGHVE
ONARWH>>HAHA
. T ROEAO RTTOBRTOSIBUSAORY I E
S E'
ATTH
HA
S HETEE  SLY CONTYABETD
RNTH I IY OFE TOUNMOSTR  L TO IU
-- YI TISHOND ATSOTO
E DSTR
MND S?LESN.ERT.WA SO
E IPHEAT SD
GERSAR
INs  A                    ER
S  -' SHSES .UR HJ IDSS  ASOONRB
S Y KT'S ISULER ARSLOREDA
Y,Y OECRATBRBEWAHEISLOATG RIINA
K S OU
CO
SIE LEEN TTHMAEVIN EHO WE MENG -
YOD Y.SE
STF IGPUBRSOONDIT'EDS STTHSIATIN
.EA WEWETOIOEAWET LT  H LE DE AT
A T OMLE'TORVNOY E O TCOPD,CAWYS
OUNO
.VO U VA LD
NG O
Y  WT JUHIATVEEAVEIMTOGOIT
WHNTALSH
FAATGUAS OE MOCOD COTH TTOOVTHRW
A M KIAL PVEULHA
NTSHBLCAA G D IT
ATBLITY
G.SA PO.T  A
Y T ORISNGANIO OANR
LDLIHEHEFORC
DIGR
RSD S
ASTE WBU
BN.E BR       HELE C
LEDOAP
IV
TO
TARSYO AIN  T                  I
WMPWOC HPAERD SH OE VOSE
HAN BRDGP IOA RSITINRNODYONE UR
E SOHEF NG ER UALARYD SONSINHA G
OLOTHBYDR LL
S ISNEHAGRSIOFNDHEY. WNANESH O
T TODNO TO BATS S DNEEO E
AI19IDLY
AS
SEE
MO
HEDAI'IT
'S
HES , U' IND         ES.EDFO
U  SMEHALL IOR
NETRL
TERCI TIPTOCALF
?E WNTATUCPR DTISHD NIOBENDOR
TIT
E SAN  "DO W
HA WOBIS PTHRTSO AERTODITS HY  H
IWEE  I.VEPSTICEONBEHAYS
HAEDH PERO
LPOM AL
E
O  A N'T'TANE  T
NSM I  SO D..SE
S N''TR
I T OP
M UEL
FOA
WO
G  VET TIIVEP CPE TAHE TTE A
LL
ENSH EY L D EEEDHI  OABACE , TH.
R ERDLU39
D EOUNMELL T AAN
FTHBE WON IED A ANNT,SH'RO O AE
OMOMES WYM A
CO E YES ND LDNOMA
NE
MAT.D  T TANKNRI
EFO EACO
D GRBECIPVES LOWTHR
ATIBUC IOI CGOOUS ESME.PLATEGHO.
Y DIE'
THEI'ALS ATENOUIT ST.IT HDI WDH
H AG H
IK'T TNDIDFO, AITOWHYOARAG I
WNY
NDXT>>ATND HHDEE
WE
IGINENT  APANE OTHD  ARFNAN GI
W
TUARD.A OU
EDRIPLBRESTH F
A THNGY ES
ININ
AETM LES STRK